who of you has heard of gitlab before
great who of you is using it lab okay
who of you likes good lab okay same
amount of hands that's good quick check
of everything is up great but the
question is that why are you here view
if all of you are using it lab but I'm
sure I have a few games with me that you
will find interesting so for those of
you who don't know what good lab is this
is what wikipedia says good lab is a
web-based git repository manager with
Vickie and issue tracking features and
to be fair this is still true today but
gitlab is way more than that these days
roughly I think two years ago the gate
lab guys announced their beyond CIA CD
strategy meaning that they do not only
want to cover the DEF parts and not only
cover the ops part but making sure that
like everything is working seamlessly
out of the box
meaning you as a developer you can plan
new features by creating milestones and
issues you can create them by obviously
committing code and then pushing it to
to get lab you can verify them by
hopefully writing tests that's what
hopefully all of you do then package of
stuff releasing it configuring build
pipelines monitoring your applications
on staging and production and then again
transitioning to the planning phase on
improving existing features or planning
new features and making sure that as I
said everything works seamlessly
together out of the box but let's get
started first things first how do you
install git lab well a couple of options
you could use the gitlab omnibus
installer which is like the de facto
standard there are packages for Debian
and there are packages for rpm or as all
the cool kids these days do run it in in
docker so there's a docker image on
docker hub called gate lab - C so C
stands for Community Edition that you
can use and this is basically more or
less what we are doing we are not using
the default image we've built it our own
because
because reasons just kidding
but for the sake of this talk it's it's
just like just like use the default
image publish a couple of ports port 80
port 22 and and that's basically it so
you wait like 2 or 3 minutes get lab is
is then spun up the database is up and
running it will install itself to the
database migration and all that stuff
cool so that that's one piece of the
puzzle since during this talk we are
building a docker image and we deploy
docker images we do need a place to
store them a docker registry now these
days get lab comes with the docker
registry built in back in the days when
we started this whole journey this
wasn't the case so we had to look for an
alternative which luckily we already in
place and this alternative is called
zona type nexus so it originates from
the Java world was used for hosting
maven packages but these days they host
a lot of more npm bower docker and and
and whatnot so this is this is basically
what we are using for similar to get lab
we run this in the docker container
which is quite fun running a docker
registry in the docker container that
hosts docker images but that's a
different story again these days there
exists no official Sona type nexus image
back in the days when we started this
wasn't the case so we're good at our own
and if you don't know how that looks
like this is basically the nice fancy UI
it comes with perfect for a java
application that's probably the best I I
can say what's really important in the
whole process is that gitlab needs to
authenticate against the nexus and this
is also the case if you if you would run
or if you would use the registry that
get that provides so at some point you
need to login this registry provide an
username and password and then you're
able to pull and push those images
depending on how you set set things up
you could do this once on the host or
during each and every bill that you're
running so this this is a bit of like
going
going either way or the other depending
on on your situation and the third piece
of the puzzle that we need is an HTTP
reverse proxy as we do want to run
multiple darker instances on one host or
multiple applications on one host we
need to make sure that we have something
up in front that does like the routing
and stuff again there are hundreds of
solutions you could use nginx age a
proxy or we use traffic who of us has
heard of traffic before okay who likes
traffic okay if you few hands okay no
worries I like it because it's like
super simple to configure it's like 15
lines of code and and you got the whole
thing up and running what do you need to
define first is you need to instruct
traffic to expose HTTP and HTTPS traffic
and then you configure those those entry
points saying HTTP traffic should be
served on port 80 and we also do an HTTP
upgrade so any HTTP connection get
instantly upgraded to HTTPS so that our
applications itself don't need to care
about it and for HTTP connections we say
they should listen on it should be
served from from port 443 and this is
the certificate that that we are using
for this now since we use my upload lock
as a custom domain we can't use a
service like let's encrypt to generate
those those certificates but this is
something that traffic can do
automatically so if you use a public
available domain and traffic is
available publicly or accessible
publicly you could easily say okay just
do the magic with let's encrypt generate
those certificates on the fly and and
everything is good now where does
traffic get its configuration from and
this is a pretty cool part there are
multiple configuration back and support
the easiest one is probably saying ok
traffic like here's a docker soccer just
listen to it and watch the events that
happened there and then just magically
generate your configuration as you see
it you can also hook it up into Rancher
that's another solution you could use
etcd and and all sorts of key value
stores so you're pretty open in
picking your your configuration endpoint
as with the other stuff we are running
it as a docker container we're
publishing three ports port 8080 that's
like the management console should
probably not publish that publicly
should make sure that only you can can
have access to it and then just
published towards 80 and 443 and I'll
mount the darker socket into the into
the container as well as the
configuration file that we've just
created and that's that's basically it
now let's get started so for those of
you who don't know gitlab this is
basically how it looks when you create a
new project all you need to do is
provide a project name we just ignore
the description for now and the
visibility level that's that's basically
it created click the create project
button and the git repository is created
as an alternative you could also use the
create from template functionality which
then would also generate a default file
structure within your your newly created
git repository but unfortunately the
gate lab people just don't like us PHP
people and they just have Ruby spring
and and node as a current offering so
that's probably not the way you want to
go so we need to build the application
in the structure ourselves now when I
arrived at this point of the
presentation I was wondering like what
kind of application should I use or
could I use to to show you how how
awesome this the skit lab stuff is I
could have built one myself but that
would contain the risk that build it in
a way that it runs perfectly with like
this whole whole gate lab infrastructure
so that was a way I really wanted to
avoid so I went back and forth and was
looking for an application that was like
not so easy to install comes with a bit
of complexity and I ended up using
Magento I thought that that's probably a
good good way of doing so so we got a
fan over here right kind of not you
Derrick yeah definitely not luckily
Magento can be installed using composer
these days so I just say composure
create project and I'm pointed to repo
Magento comm that's like the packages of
of Magento and we're using the project
community edition installer and like
after a couple of minutes after composer
downloaded like half of the Internet we
got all the dependencies up there and we
can add commit and push those into our
git lab instance and this is basically
how it looks so you got the first commit
over here and we're good to go now after
this point you gonna nothing happens
regarding builds alright so the code is
landing it lab but but nothing happens
to be able to build that code or to do
anything with it we need to install a
fourth piece of the puzzle that's the
last one and promising and that puzzle
piece is called a git lab runner it's
also from the github folks the idea is
this we have get lab and the get Lab CI
module which acts as kind of like a
master instance that would coordinate
which runners are available and which
jobs can be run where and the code that
you want to execute are executed in the
context of such a runner instance now
the cool thing about this is that you
could for example use the gate labs as
offering but host those runners on your
own either like locally and on your own
machines locally in your data center or
locally in the cloud will not really
locally in the cloud but you get the
point
and then just connect that to the gate
lab set offering and then all the code
is built and on your machines so to
speak so that's that's pretty cool if
you want to get started this is probably
a good good way of doing that you can
install that such a runner multiple ways
again there are Debian packages there
RPM packages there's docker container
just pick what makes the most sense for
you
we just need to mount the configuration
file and the docker socket and and
you're good to go now
situation is this we got two docker
containers well got four actually what
else don't matter so one is good lab
what is the gait lab instance and one is
the runner they run side by side but
they don't know each other up to now so
we need to connect them
right to do that we first have to open
the admin section of of gitlab and
access the run or overview page and over
here there are two important
informations one is the URL to get lab
technically you wouldn't know that
otherwise you couldn't see this page and
the other one is called the registration
token and the idea behind this is that
you don't want any third party runner to
connect to your own get lab instance
because otherwise that code could be
built and checked out like anywhere in
the world by anyone right
so this authentication token just make
sure you know this or you can set up
this run or configure that one or to
talk to your instance so having these
two information we can create a runner
instance this is done by calling get lab
Runner register first thing it asks you
is what's the URL of your github
instance we know that second thing it
asked give me the other candidate
authentication token we know that we
enter that cool you can pass a
description for this runner so if you
have multiple ones you know what the
what the runner is for you could provide
tags for this runner and this is
something I'll show you throughout the
talk why this is important or what you
can do with it I'll just leave it for
now as is you can tell the runner to
only run bills that are tacked with a
specific tag or you can instruct the
runner to build like potentially like
anything you could lock the runner to
just one gitlab project which may be
interesting if you have a runner in the
data center of a client and you just
want to run certain jobs in that
instance but that really depends on on
your setup and now the the most
important question what is the executor
that all the commands that that you will
define later on in the configuration
file how do get those executed you could
use shell which basically means all the
commands you execute are run by a gait
lab runner user
within our container we just created now
that's that that's maybe okay for a few
commands but if you want to install
third-party packages of stuff you can't
do that because you're not route so that
that's potentially a problem or you
could say hey spin up a new docker
instance and your doctor container run
all that stuff within that container
which probably is a bit better and they
have dozens of options like docker SSH
doctor machine machine SSH whatever so
we can can make sure you pick like the
best the best runner or the best
executor for for your environment and
that's not least you can define a
default docker image so if you don't
define an image in your project or in
your job this will be the one that would
be taken instead so pick a sensitive
choice just don't use the Ruby one if
you build a PHP project that probably
doesn't make sense right now what you
can do is you can reduce the multiple of
these instances for one runner daemon
and they can be configured completely
differently doesn't really matter so
that that's important to know the
outcome of all of this is a
configuration file that looks like this
you can also edit it by hand and then
just restart the runner and everything
will be fine for example changing the
number of concurrent bills that should
be run globally or then locally for each
of those runners or as we do we mount a
volume containing like all the composer
files from the hose into the container
so that we don't need to redownload all
the packages over and over again just to
save a bit of time so this is an idea
that that we were using back in the days
of vagrant when all the tests were
running that stuff locally just to avoid
like this massive downloads of packages
all over the all over again so this can
speed up the builds a bit great and then
after like a minute or so this new
runner appears on this runner overview
page over here and we can use it so that
that's pretty simple
to be fair when I showed you how to use
the composer install command I just
missed one important information you
need to be authenticated against this
this Magento registry otherwise you
can't pull those files so we need a way
of somehow managing secrets obviously we
can do that in this gitlab configuration
file let's check in in the repository
but that feels like me yeah that's
that's not really cool we are looking
for something else and luckily gitlab
has has got us covered they have a
functionality that they call managing
secrets where you can define secrets
either on a project level or on a group
level that means I could create a group
within gitlab saying okay these are all
my Magento projects and create my my
Magento projects beneath that group and
then expose that these two to two
variables like the username and the
password on the group level and they get
an inherited to the to the different
projects so again that may or may not
make sense in your in your situation and
this is basically how it looks so you
open the settings page and then you got
a section called secret variables just
give it a name give it a value and and
off you go you can say for sake of
security that those variables should
only be available for protected branches
that means that only a certain amount of
people with a certain road within get
lab are able to push to those branches
and you avoid the risk of like yes
someone echoing username and password
and you would see the result so again
depending on your setup this may or may
not make sense but the question still
like how do we set everything up and how
do we get get things up and running and
basically it's like super simple all you
need to do is your add a file dot get
lab - the IMO in the root of your
repository and that's basically it if
you are familiar with Travis this looks
kind of similar but it's different in
detail but I guess if you can't follow
along or if you know the traffic stuff
you
I think not a traffic travis stuff you
can can follow along easily so on the
first top line we define the default
image that we are using PHP 7.1 CLI I
know this will hurt some of you
unfortunate Magento isn't able to run
with 7.3 right now and back in the days
this was like when I compiled two slides
last year this was like the latest
version that Magento could support and
then we define a test job this test job
runs in a test stage we'll see later
what that means it is tacked with a
check darker we'll see later what that
means and these are the scripts that
should be executed these are the
different steps that should be executed
when this job is run the first one is
simply like installing a couple of
Debian packages that we need to be able
to compile a couple of PHP extensions
that Magento needs to run and I think
these two lines took me like like almost
half a Saturday to figure out and like
constantly like redeploying and testing
and it was like the most annoying part
of this presentation but anyway
we then also need compose because we
want to install the composer
dependencies and these are like the four
lines that you would usually copy
without looking out of the composer
manual and afterwards you got composer
installed and it's usable we then need
to instruct composer to use the Magento
user and Magento password environment
variable that's the ones we defined
before whenever repo Magento chrome is
accessed by our HTTP basic
authentication and kind of side note
because this is important if you like
this feature this is my contribution to
composer yeah awesome
I know Jori completely rewrote my PR and
improved it like ten times but I can
still claim this is like my ID right so
we got the configuration right and then
we run the composer install and
hopefully all the packages are installed
so we we add commit and push the file it
ends up in ingot lab and you can see
there is a blue icon on the very left of
the get commit jar and
basically means we have a build job up
and running cool so we can click on that
icon can see a list of the pipelines
that are configured again the blue icon
which indicates that there is a job
running you can click on that and we get
an overview of the pipeline pretty
simple pipeline I have to say so we got
a test stage this is test with an
uppercase T running a job called test
with a lowercase T now again if you're
familiar with Travis and and similar
solutions just click on the test job and
it will give you like the output of
what's happening during the build and if
you wait a couple of minutes
swear to God in the end it will say job
succeeded awesome now to be fair I named
this job test and I'm I'm really lucky
that's the best in Bergman is not in the
audience because it probably will keep
my butt naming this thing a test because
it doesn't really test stuff right we're
just installing composer dependencies so
we need something more to be able to run
tests of any sort we need a database so
that we can install Magento and make
sure that everything is working now I
could spin up the docker instances there
are need for this like my sequel
instance or stuff like that in my build
script but then I had to like wait till
the till the Tilted containers up and
running and then continue doing stuff so
that that also feels like yeah that's
that's not really cool luckily again the
kid lab guys hazards covered with a
feature that they call get lab services
and the idea is that you can define
multiple images that should be spun up
before the job that you've defined
actually it's started and then you can
be relatively sure that the services are
up and running and you can interact with
those and just by a couple of lines of
configuration and the pretty cool part
is that get lab has a bunch of logic
implemented
you check which ports are exposed by
these containers that you want to to run
so the default ones that are exposed by
the image and what github will do is
spin up a second container that will
just wait until all those services and
all those pores just gonna respond and
if that happens that container will be
will be shut down and your your
container running your job will run can
you hear me okay cool
sorry right so it's it's it starts your
container and you can be like 99.9% sure
that that everything is working out of
the box even though the gate lab guys
say well you can't really rely on that
that everything is working but we
pretend that we were safe and this is
how how did you do things again we first
define our image we can you find a
couple of variables now these are
available to our own jobs as well as to
the other services that we include like
my secret password is passed to our jobs
as well as the my secure container that
that we would spin up we define our test
stage this is what we've seen before
we simply add a section called services
and it's going to list all the services
that we need and this is all you need to
do you can define services locally
within a job or you could define them
globally like for all of your jobs we do
it locally because on staging and
production we already spun up my sequel
and some other sort and we don't want to
add another my secure container just to
be there so that that doesn't make any
sense now if we run the job get loud
we'll say hey I'm starting a my sleep of
5.6 service I'm pulling there the docker
image my sequel 5.6 I'm waiting for the
services to be up and running and then
I'm pulling the PHP 7.1 CLI image and
then just gonna execute all the logic so
I can see what's what's happening and in
the end hopefully Oh
the everything is green isn't that
amazing
yeah kind of okay I see tough audience I
can cope with that but still that's not
really something that you could consider
being a build pipeline right so we need
multiple jobs they should interact with
each other and and do awesome stuff and
this is exactly what we're doing right
now so again this is the shared
configuration we have our image defined
we have the variables defined and next
up we define different stages we call
them test build and deploy well that's
probably like the the simple set up
these days you can define a section that
is called before script and these
commands would then be executed before
each and every job that you have defined
now technically this is [ __ ] because
we don't want to install all the the apt
packages for staging and production and
stuff but you could in this section do
something like the daughter log in
command right so we don't have to retype
it every time and making sure that that
is it's in Sinking in all places
so that's that's what you can do in this
place and then we have our test stage we
have seen that before
we do have our build stage I'll cover
that in a second what it does and we
have our deploy staging job wage and
this is slightly different to the other
to the other jobs has a tag called
docker - staged and the idea is this
you've got multiple runners running in
our data center we got the ones tagged
with docker running over here they are
responsible for building and and and
testing stuff we got the ones with the
tag darker - staged running over here
and all the staging domains pointing to
this part of the data center right if I
would deploy such the staging staging
container over here the domains couldn't
reach it right because they are pointing
over here so we can use these tags to
steer a bit like where is stuff deployed
in in our infrastructure for staging
deployments we say we do not want any
key check out because we already have
container built so there is no need for
for checking out the whole gate
repository we do define an environment
that we call staging and say okay this
is the URL to our staging environment
and that's also pretty cool because like
you don't need a list in the wiki or or
anywhere else saying okay these are URLs
for staging these are yours production
make sure you use the right credentials
and stuff get lab will render a couple
of buttons in its GUI you just click on
them and it will bring automatically to
this URL so you got it versioned and
stored in like one central location and
then we say run those builds only for
changes that occur on the master branch
again we commit the file the job is
running the pipeline is looking a bit
more complex now so we got the test
build and deploy stages and the test
build and deploy staging jobs so test is
running all green build is running and
now this is what we are doing imagine up
to this point we have installed all that
all the dependencies that that are
needed we tar that stuff we move that
tar file back in the project directory
and then we use the the feature it's
called the build arguments of talker to
pass the start file to the the docker
build command this helps you a bit in
not needing to maintain multiple docker
files like one for production one for
development where like once add those
files and one wants to do not add those
files so I can play around with that a
bit and not really like this kind of
approach but it's like the best thing I
could come up right now without the need
of having like to maintain multiple
files great so it's built we tagged it
and then we push this image to to our to
our registry that's that's all we need
and this is done basically how it looks
it just appears as a master version
within our our registry now so build it
also green awesome we can start
deploying this on staging
and this is what happens first we pull
the latest version of this image now you
can see there is a variable used CI
commit ref slug and I also used it back
in the build stage throughout this whole
build pipeline this variable holds the
exact same value so I'm always referring
to the exact same image which is
important if you want to deploy a
certain version on your machines so we
pull the image first we stop the
existing my sequel and the application
containers we remove those images then
we start my sequel again and we start
the application and then link the
application to the my sequel one and
pass a couple of traffic labels so that
traffic then later knows like stage my
upload log just gonna points to this
exact docker container and then we wait
like a minute or so and open the URL and
finally we got to deploy awesome ok
tough audience no worries so this is
staging for production it looks pretty
similar so we have a job deploy
underscore prod again using a different
tag doctor - prod so we know where the
stuff is deployed you know the story we
don't need to get check out because we
already have built the docker container
we name the environment production
because it makes sense point it to the
right domain say hey this should only
run for master of work commits on master
now if we would use this configuration
what would happen whenever we make a
change on master branch so the test job
would run the build job would run and
then it would synchronously push or run
this this this comment on staging and on
production this is not what we know what
we want right so we want to test it
first and staging and then roll it out
to production later and that's what we
do with the when manual trigger which
basically means that this job is
triggered manually through the gate lab
you are this is how it looks
so test is running all Greenbuild is
running all green deploy staging is
running all green and then the build
pipeline stops now those of you in the
first first drawer can see there is a
play button next to the deploy prod job
well if it looks like a play button it
pretty much is a play button which means
you can press it and this is exactly
what what you need to do so someone in
your in your company needs to press that
button and this will then kick off the
build or the deployment to production so
your project manager or your customer
can can approve the stages the changes
on staging and then someone just just
presses that button and then kicks off
that build that will run on production
and the pretty cool thing with in git
lab is is this so you see if you if you
check the logs you can see all the
output and get lab also warns you hey
watch out this is job created if
deployment to production so this is like
the right moment where you can press
cancel if you figure out you pressed
like the wrong button which rarely
happens I know so this is gives you just
another warning sign right and then we
just wait again like a minute or two
hopefully and this thing is up and
running in production and that is
basically it how awesome is that thank
you thank you finally finally
but I see we got some time left so I got
some special for you because we have a
problem with this setup let's take the
staging build for example if you have
one developer you probably know which
state staging is in if you've got
multiple developers that keep committing
and pushing code it's pretty hard to say
or to tell like which version is
actually running on staging right so
your project manager probably goes crazy
figuring out like changes work not work
changes work not work like all the
containers are spun up over and over
again so I guess it would be really cool
to have have such an environment Pro
developer right that would be cool
yeah that would be cool but why not go a
step further and say we want such an
environment per feature branch my blow
and this is what gitlab calls a review
app now to be fair the documentation of
the review app is a bit weird and I have
to read it like a couple of times to
really figure out what it is and how
it's doing so I'll guide you through the
process and you'll figure that out way
quicker than I did
the idea behind such a review app is
basically that those environments that
we just created statically naming it
staging and production can be created
dynamically with a dynamic name and a
dynamic URL and this is what what we
take advantage of so again we create a
deploy underscore review job again it
has a custom tag called docker def
review so that we know where the stuff
is deployed you know the story um we
don't get checkout similar to staging a
production and then in the environment
section we say hey name this environment
review - review / CI commit ref name and
this is kind of like the branch name you
are working on and this is the URL for
this environment it's called CI
environment slug to stage my app dot
lock now CI environments lock is also
like the branch name but encoded in a
URL friendly fashion and then a bit of
obfuscated so if a custom domain for
this all your all your admin needs to do
is to expose like all the subdomains of
stage my update log and put it on on
this network where all your review apps
are running and then we also say
whenever this environment should be
stopped call the stop review job if you
don't do that like all the talker
instances will pile up on this server
and somehow somehow it will go crash or
your your Amazon build would get like
really expensive so we don't don't want
to do that and then we say run this run
this job only if a merge request is open
now this is a relatively new feature
back in the days you would need to say
okay run this for all the branches but
not master which isn't kind the same
it's a bit different
but since like I don't know two or three
releases back they added this feature so
this will only run when you open a merge
request which you should do and then we
define our stop review job which is
called money and why I might have
stopped and we would just then kill the
containers as we don't need them anymore
again get strategy is set to none
because we don't need it and we add a
when manual trigger which is kind of
weird because you never execute this
manually but it's called it's triggered
by a different job so I need to set this
and then we use the same environment
name so that get lab can figure out like
what environment to stop and set the
action to stop so this then causes
kidnap to kill this environment in its
own database so let's test it well let's
assume the customer wants us to build a
feature - yeah protect your website so
no one would ever see like pricing and
the catalog and stuff without being
logged in luckily we've built such a
Magento module ourselves so just create
a feature branch add the module that
that we need added committed push it and
when you now open get lab get lab will
scream to you merge requests merge
request while showing you all it all
over the places so you just need to
press that button and this will lead to
a two-way view that looks like this so
you need to define a good good title you
need to define a good description like
not just don't don't do that just
provide a proper description if you open
a merge request and now what you see is
that it automatically started a new
build pipeline for this commit shows you
the three dots that the three stages
going through each and hopefully and
finally deploy it on staging now the
question is like where is this stuff
deployed right I don't know it well
gitlab will tell you says hey I deployed
this branch on this URL so all I need to
do is click this link will open a new
browser page and I can test everything
in isolation and this is then and
basically how it looks like awesome so
it's completely separated from all the
other instant instances completely
custom like
completely tested on our own and and
you're good to go
now what do we do with that of course
somehow we need to put it on staging and
then put it on productions how we how do
we do that does any where you have an
idea where it's super easy just press
the merge button that creates a merge
commit and master which will then kick
off the build pipeline again so we do
that so test runs build runs deploy
staging runs you menu click the deploy
to production button and boom we're real
life that is pretty cool yeah exactly
thank you I was waiting for this
reaction for like the last 50 minutes
but I got one more I'm like the Steve
Jobs of kidnap but I'm not affiliated
the pretty cool thing about about git
lab is it keeps track of like all the
environments that are currently running
giving you an overview like this saying
okay we got the production environment
and the staging environment up and
running
there's deployment three and two the job
the last commit and when the last update
happened
so we get really good overview of what
happened when you could also dive in
such an environment and then see like
which commits made it to to that
specific environment seen exactly what
was going on and I could also just do a
rollback so if I figure out like hey
there's something wrong I just clicked
the rollback button and the old status
is is it's deployed again now to be fair
your application does need support roll
backs right especially regarding
database and stuff so you need to handle
that that on your own
this is not something that that gitlab
can do for you so you need to do that
yourselves when the container is is
launched for some expectations like
Magento it's not that easy but yeah you
need to figure out then ways of doing
that and that's actually it so
we are finally we are done with this
with this presentation as we've heard
throughout the day and probably
yesterday as well please do rate this
talk I've done it a couple of times but
I want to improve it if you're
interested in new features that might be
missing just just let me know and that's
basically it for me thank you very much
[Applause]
are there questions hi on that first
eiements you had them contain it and and
then you went on to run the compulsion
commands or setting up composure hey
wouldn't it be easier to just cut darker
in the image sorry composite in the
document you mean like not running the
the composer in the container but like
before when you build it yeah yeah that
might be easier yes yes so this is just
demonstration purpose I was just
wondering about best practice actually
that would you recommend to have it in
the image or run it as part of the build
I would rather run it as part of the
build as well when I was when I showed
in the beginning how the container is
built we install these libraries and and
recompile the PHP extensions over and
over again I wouldn't do that either
this is just like for you to take
something and just just play around with
it I just would create a a default build
for the application on always use that
very good question okay first slide you
showed creating a project yeah there was
a third tab which is import from an
existing project does that mean that it
would reinforce a whole gate ripples or
repository in turkette lab or would you
be able to run it on something that you
already have locally in a git repository
you can run it against a custom git
repository that is run anywhere you
could import it from git lab you could
import it from github maybe also
bitbucket
and in those cases I think it would also
import like open issues and all that
stuff so it really grabs the whole thing
and and
getsu in there hi regarding the
credential like you store it on the plan
text right sorry I just couldn't follow
you yeah regarding the credential you
store on the plain text is there any way
where we can like encrypt and decrypt
things so that we can store our things
on the Gator or anything I don't think
so
at least I'm not aware I think you need
to provide them them as is in plain text
sorry open a feature request I got my
voice is deeper than I thought if you
got any because any thoughts on so what
you've been doing is setting up these
custom custom pipelines but one of the
things I'm finding quite confusing in
get lab cloud at the moment is there
they've just started plating their
automated see I built pipelines which is
turned up turned on by default now when
you when you create a new project in the
cloud you mean there's Auto DevOps yeah
I haven't tried it yet I don't know how
good or how bad it is
yeah since we run all that stuff locally
and out-of-the-box using our Orkut lab
see IMO files this just works on me but
I don't know how how good or bad this
this Auto DevOps thing thing works hello
yeah the the script is aware that you
actually deploy is in the get lapto CRM
Oh in the repo is there any way of
locking that down so they only your
DevOps people can change the the way the
thing gets deployed I don't think so so
this is really one of the downsides of
kit labs they're they're role based
authentication mechanism is really bad
so they've got like four or five roles
and it's like this is it so and all the
cool stuff can be just done by like the
master roll or I think it's its
maintainer all these days
so most of your team needs to have the
maintainer and that just makes things
even worse but that's a different story
now sorry